magnito Aragorn and Elizabeth Swann and
a movie about psychoanalysis actually
sounds kind of cool sex male family
child giggles a Dangerous Method is
directed by David Cronenberg who's a
very prolific director who's made
classic films for many years one of my
favorites is the dead zone Christopher
Walken Stephen King adaptation and not a
lot of people know about this film tells
the story of Sigmund Freud played by
Viggo Mortensen and his associate played
by Michael Fassbender who are just
inventing a whole idea of psychoanalysis
how to treat a patient using therapy and
really delving into that person's mind
trying to figure out what the problem is
so that they can solve their own problem
whatever it might be the patient in
question is Keira Knightley who was
raised by a very abusive father and that
has traumatized her and had a lot of
hardships with her in her life they're
using her it kind of as a test to try to
figure out where everything is with
their ideas professor Freud but bu I
just open the door it's real men like
yourself to walk through it
that she's the one people expanded to
treatment this is a very good film one
of the things I really appreciated about
it was the acting my word Michael
Fassbender this year is exploding Google
Martin Singh is always good he is so so
good in this film but for me the thing
that really stuck in my memory was Keira
Knightley in this film a lot of people
complained about her performance and
said it was really over the top lots of
jaw work and everything but it was
really effective for me she wasn't
afraid to make herself look ugly at all
and I thought that was a big plus for a
performance because usually actresses
like that you know they were like tell
me about the first time you can remember
being beaten by your father
the kicks I didn't week I really liked
the style that David Cronenberg directed
this movie in a lot of these shots of
Keira Knightley where she was making
these faces and just you know her whole
body was just contorting and everything
he he close-ups he didn't cut away from
this beautiful woman making these really
nasty faces and I really think that that
really helped a lot of the first half of
this film's intensity now is your little
Russian patient that was the most
dramatic improvement
he certainly if you ever want to take
the initiative I live in that building
there the phone dragged a little bit as
it went on and towards the latter half
it wasn't as intense and dramatic as the
film opened but I still really think
this is a good film it's not as good as
some of David Cronenberg's other films
but I do really think it's worth your
time if you're into him as a director
I'm going to give a dangerous method of
B+ used too much the connectors
sometimes you have to do something
unforgivable just to be able to go on
living
if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel against tapenade